was hast du jetzt oh meine Mutter hat wieder
auf Folgen gedrückt ich habe jetzt wieder
17 das freut mich für dich auch ganz schön
bei mir so
800.000 ja das ist angemessen
wirklich sehr schön super wusstest Du eigentlich
Franz der Münchhausen und der kann ja die
kannten sich
der berühmte Philosoph und Antisemit aus
Königsberg an der Pregel übrigens
haben die eine Wetter abgeschlossen und der
der kant hat zum Münchhausen gesagt also
München hat er gesagt am Ende der Geschichte
sieht die von uns bei fester Glaube das wird
sich durchsetzen klare Formen Verstand Empirie
Wissenschaft das bleibt am Ende die Geschichte
ist eine lange Gerade Linie die aufsteigt
hin zu mehr Aufklärung und von uns und da
münchenhausen Münchhausen hat er gesagt
immer weißt du was ich werde da gern dagegen
ich glaube die Geschichte am Ende der Geschichte
siegt der achtbeinige Hase und es wird eine
Zeit kommen da kann jeder seine Filter Bubble
zurecht labern wie sie ihm gefällt und was
deine gerade Linie anbelangt die kannst du
immer schön hinten reinprägeln das glaube
ich nämlich nicht ich glaube am Ende ist
nur der Augenblick da der verweilt für die
nächste Push Nachricht das ist mein Ding
und ich glaube die Geschichte ist irgendwie
auf meiner Seite so haben die gewettete top
nee jetzt kann ich natürlich fragen wer da
wohl gewonnen
[Applaus] die Nachtigall die Nachtigall ist
das beste Pferd im Stall
Wissenschaft dort ist eine Meinung die muss
jeder sagen dürfen Wissenschaft oh ist eine
Meinung die muss jeder sagen dürfen morgens
um sechs sprach der Sprit die Flucht wegen
Weg Flaschen raus und dann ins Fitti ich bin
verwirrt ich hab Couscous im Gehäuse ich
bin verwirrt ich hab Couscous im Gehäuse
ich denke bismar kommt jetzt in die Oberstufe
[Musik]
da läuft ein Hase mit acht Beinen hier bin
ich richtig ich will mir scheinen der Alu
Hut der Alu Hut der steht dir heute richtig
gut tut gut ich bin für ein selfie von der
Klippe gefallen
Wissenschaft oh ist eine Meinung die muss
jeder sagen wird Wissenschaft oh ist seine
Meinung die muss jeder sagen dass ich hatte
Esel im Galopp verloren ich hatte Esel im
Galopp verloren dich hat der Esel im Galopp
verloren ich hatte Esel in Galopp verloren
ich hab die hier nach Tempo in mir ich hab
dir hier ich hab die hier nach Tempo
[Musik]
das Fleisch wird dunkel auf der Grill [Musik]
die Rolling Stones mussten wir Konzert verschieben
starke Stürme haben ihren Katamaran erfasst
die backlinerinnen trudeln der Atlantik vielen
Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit [Applaus]